어 2019년도 대비 2023년 신용
카드 결제액이 제일 높은 데는
[음악]
바로네 안녕 사람입니다 어 요즘 그
외국인 관광객들 그 한류 평을 타면서
좀 한국에 좀 굉장히 좀 많이 오고
있는데 오늘은 외국인 관광계 카드
결제 내역을 좀 분석을 해 가지고 좀
외국인들이 어디 가서 어떤 상품을 좀
주로 사는지 좀 영상을 다뤄보도록
하겠습니다 아무래도 외국인분들이 좀
많아지면 그 상권의 영향이 좀 굉장히
많거든요 그래서 여러분들이이 부분도
좀 주목해서 보시면 좋을 것 같습니다
코로나를 일단 좀 걸치면서 트렌드가
좀 많이 바뀐 거 같아요 그래서
과거에는 원래 이제 백화점이나
면세점을 주로 좀 단체 관광이 좀
줄을 잃었다면 어 최근에는 좀 이렇게
하프를 많이 찾아다니는 그런 개인
관광이 좀 대세가 된 거 같습니다
그래서 코로나 이전인 어 2019년과
23년 어 두 회를 기준으로 좀
이야기를 해보도록 하겠습니다 어
2019년도 대비 2023년 어 심용
카드 결제액이 제일 높은 데는 바로
명동입구 코로나 때 좀 굉장히 좀
영향을 많이 받았던 그런 곳인데
최근에 이제 코로나가 좀 풀리면서 좀
이렇게 외국인 관광객들이 들어오면서
아무래도 명동 좀 많이 찾은 거
같아요 그 예를 들면 2019년도
2,570 원이었던 명동 내 결제액이
지난해 6189억 원으로 어 무려
3,610 원이 되었습니다 그래서
관광객들이 돌아오면서 좀 공시 문제도
많이 좀 해결이 됐는데 쿠시먼의
따르면 2022년 4분기 기준으로
명동의 공실률이 무려 42% 있다고
합니다 근데 지난해 4분기는
99.4% 좀 크게 좀 개선이
되었습니다 그리고 업종별로 좀 좀
따지면 종합 소매업 매출액이 이
증가가 되게 높았고 2019년
82억원에 불과했던 종합 소매점
소비는 지난해 1384억 원으로 무려
1700%네 넘게 성장했습니다 그래서
중심에는 올리브 0과 다이소가
있습니다 저도 뭐 최근에 올리브영
갔을 때도 외국인분들이 굉장히 좀
많이 오시더라고요 과거에는 백화점이나
이제 면세점의 이제 고가 화장품을 좀
많이 구매했던
관광객들이 즘에는 가성비 좋고 다양한
제품을 좀 많이 살려고 하는데 그게
딱 이제 올리브 형에 발길이 좀 몰린
것으로 좀 보여지고 그래서 실제
올리브영의 지난해 외국인 매출은 전년
대비해서 무려 660% 증가했다고
합니다 그래서 지금 명동에는 임대
문이라는 현수막이 좀 많이 사라졌어요
코로나 때는 정말 진짜 거의 다 이제
임대 분이가 붙여져 있었는데 어
최근에는 수막이 좀 많이
줄어들었습니다 그리고 관광객들을 좀
보니까 일본 관광객들이 제일 많았나
봐요 우리나라도 좀 일본은 많이
갔지만 일본 관광객들도 한국을 좀
많이 보왔습니다 일본 관광객 소비가
135억 원으로 가장 많았고
뒤를이어서 싱가포 다에 미국 순으로
이제 좀 나타났다고 합니다서 과거에는
좀 중국인 관광객 단체 관광객 좀
이미지가 많았는데 요즘에는 좀 다양한
국가에 어 사람들이 좀 많이 와서
소비를 하는 것으로 좀 보여집니다
명의 를이어서 늘어난 상권은 홍대
입구랑 강남 앞구정 청담 순이었습니다
그래서 매출액이 천억이 증가액이
1천억이 넘는 곳이 이제이네 곳인데
상권만 컨셉이 되게 명확한 거 같아요
그래서 홍대는 의류 그다음에
강남압구정 청담은 피부과 성형의과
같은 특학 병원의 외국인들이 소비를
하는 거 같습니다 그리고 홍대가 되게
많이 좀 커진 거 같아요 이제
2019년도에 920억원 였던게
2023년 3250억 원까지 253%
매출이 증가했습니다 강남과 진짜 좀
큰 차이가 나지 않은 그런 매이고
홍대가 좀 외국인 관광객들한테 좀
이렇게 패션으로 좀 많이 좀 과을
받기 시작했고 원래 기존에는 가로
스킬이나 동대문에 좀 많이 외국인
분들이 소개를 했는데 거기서 좀 이제
홍대 쪽으로 좀 많이 이전한 것으로
좀 보여집니다 그 홍대는 숙박도 되게
좀 핫한 왔습니다 그래서 거기
홍대입구역이 공항선 있어서 인천
공항을 왔다 갔다 하기가 되게 좀
편해서 홍대 입구역 인근으로 숙박을
많이 잡는 경우가 많은데 통대 숙박
그 매출도 좀 많이 늘어났다고 합니다
그래서 원래는
2019년도에는 그때 카드 매출액이
28억 원이었는데 지난해는 무려
602억 원으로 엄청 크게
상승했습니다 그래서 홍대가 좀
패션이라면 압구정과 청단 은 좀 의료
매화로 좀 특화된 특화 병원에 좀
많이 외국인들이 좀 소비를 하는 거
같습니다 그래서 2019년도에
396억 원이었던게 지금 지난해
183억 원으로 정말 급증을
했습니다네 그리고 좀 눈에 띄게 많이
오른 곳은 성수동이 좀 되게
대표적입니다 성수동이 원래
2019년도에 카드 결제 49억
원에서 지난해 527억 원으로 무려
1000% 가까운 성장을 좀
보였습니다 그래서 성수는 홍대랑 좀
비슷하게 패션 소비가 좀 많이 있었던
거 같아요 의류 매출이 19억 원에서
222억 원으로 좀 많이 올랐습니다
의류를 제외한 뭐 신발이나 가방도
원래 이제 10억 원에서 104억
원으로 약 한 배 정도 좀 늘어났고
그리고 뭐 신촌 이대나 뭐 인사동이나
삼청도 또 뭐 꾸준히 방문을 했고
신촌이나 이대상권 같은 경우에는 홍대
랑 그렇게 거리가 멀지 않기 때문에
좀 이렇게 반사이익을 보는 부분이 좀
있는 거 같습니다 인사동이나 삼청동
숙박업이 되게 매출이 늘었나 봐요
19년도에 85억 원이었던게 작년에
255억 원으로 굉장히 좀 많이
상승을 했습니다 근데 아무래도
인사동이나 삼 삼청동은 일반적인 숙박
없서 보다는 한옥 이라든지 좀 이렇게
한국 느낌에 맞는 그런 숙박 공수가
좀 많이 있는 거 같은데 그런 데는
좀 외국인들이 좀 많이 찾아오지
않았나네 이렇게 예상을 합니다 그리고
조금 특이했던게 인사동이나 삼청동
같은 경우에는 일본이라는 뭐 아시아권
사람보다는 미국이나 아일랜드
오스트렐리아 등 좀 서부권에 계신
분들이 방문을 많이 했다고 합니다
그리고 여의도 같은 경우에는 이런
대형 쇼핑몰이 많잖아요 그래서
여의도도 좋지 않은 그런 어 성장성을
보인 거 같고 그다음 잠실 같은
경우에도 원래 192억 원에서
33억원으로 좀 카드 결제가 많이
줄었다고 하니다 외국인들도 최근에 좀
트렌드가 많이 바뀐 거 같아요 그래서
원래는 이제 단체 관광이 좀 많았다가
좀 개인 관광으로 좀 많이 줄어들고
좀 하프를 많이 찾아 다니는 그런
트렌드로 좀 바뀌었고 명동을 가더라도
이런 대형 뭐 쇼핑몰이라는 이런 데를
가는게 아니라 가성비 조 어 예를
들어서 올리브 형이나 뭐 다이소를 좀
많이 가는 편이고 신사동에 원래 이제
성형이나
이런 패션 때문에 좀 많이 갔던
외국인 분들이 패션 같은 경우에는
홍대로 좀 홍대는 되게 눈에 상승을
했고 성수도 좀 많이 그쪽으로 가면서
외국인들이 좀 많이 찾는 곳으로 좀
된 거 같습니다 원래 성형하고 신사동
쪽으로 많이 갔지만 그게 이제 앞구정
청 그 좀 로데오 인근으로 좀 많이
어 이동을 한 것으로 좀 보여지고
그래서
여러분들이 외국인 관광계 이런
트렌드도 좀 보시면 좋을 거 같아요
그래서 앞으로 어 상권에 좀 외국인
관광객들이 많이 찾는지 여러분들도 좀
관심 갖고 보시면 좋을 것 같습니다
그래서 좀 이런 트렌드를 좀
파악하셨나요
영상은 여기까지 하고요 다음 시간에
또 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다 m